in my department we issue an
infinity license to anyone who can
navigate the paradox infested waters of
infinity
here's mine just so you know i'm not
lying i'm not making this up
my favorite part of the infinity license
it's the
expiration date expires next year
it can guarantees that it will never
expire see
once you understand infinity your mind
is changed forever
i i wasn't always an expert on infinity
i wasn't always licensed
i grew up in a small town in wisconsin
stevens point
and i remember arguments on the
playground back in madison school
my dad makes more than yours
it was always about our dads most of our
moms worked too
then the numbers game began my dad makes
a million dollars
you know both my teacher parents were
teachers
i'm already overestimating their
salaries by a couple of digits
my dad makes a trillion dollars my dad
makes a bazillion dollars
and then the moment of truth my dad
makes infinity dollars
and that's when things got really
interesting
see we knew that infinity was bigger
than all the regular numbers
we knew but we also knew we could go
higher than that
infinity plus one two times infinity
dollars
infinity squared you know we were just
learning about exponents
infinity to the infinity you know
i didn't know it then but we were
getting into some really serious
mathematical questions
and those questions hadn't been settled
just a century earlier
today we're talking about the beginning
of infinity in all of its strange
paradoxical kid befuddling glory
let's start by imagining you own a hotel
your hotel is special
it has infinitely many rooms there they
are room one room two room three room
four stretching off down
an infinite hallway the hotel infinity
sometimes people call this hilbert's
hotel no
this has been known for a long time but
this present uh
version of it it's due to hilbert in the
1924 lecture
lucky for you business is good no
vacancies all of your rooms are full
should you hang the no vacancy sign out
in front
well what if someone comes and really
desperately wants a room
actually there's no problem you see you
get on the hotel's pa system and you say
everyone please pack up your things and
move down one room
person in room one moves to two the
person in two moves to three three to
four
in general the person in room n moves to
room n plus one
it's a good general rule that everyone
can follow
so how does this solve your problem you
see
your new guest your new guest just goes
in room one it's vacated
it's empty that's this is very different
from
finite hotels see this was easy
you could add somebody to a hotel that
was already full
it gets more crazy so strap in
what if your new visitor was extremely
picky and demanded a particular room
i need to stay in a perfect room number
496 will do
can you accommodate somebody like that
sure there's still no problem you get on
the pa system
if your room is number 496 or above
please move down one room 496 becomes
vacant
and the picky visitor is happy
what if it's not just one visitor
what if 10 new guests arrive you can do
that too
if your room number is n please move to
n plus 10.
number one goes to 11 2 goes to 12
and then the first 10 rooms are free in
fact
that same strategy works for any finite
number of guests
you have a million people show up at
your hotel a billion people
you can still do that
this is really really strange you know
if you have finitely many rooms and
they're all filled you can't accommodate
anyone much less a million people
no some sizes of infinity seem different
but they aren't and remember the key
thing is about
matching about a one-to-one
correspondence
so what happens if infinitely many new
guests arrive
and the hotel infinity has no vacancies
infinitely many new guests
how do you accommodate these new folks
well let's think of it this way suppose
your hotel is full
and a bus pulls up like the bus line
infinity and on the bus are infinitely
many people
in in seats numbered one two three four
five all the way down
now can you move the current hotel
guests around to accommodate for these
new folks
this is clearly a much harder question
but if you think for a while you'll find
a solution
the easiest way i know to do this is
just to tell to the
hotel guests on the pa if you're in room
number n
please room move to room number two n
so the person in one goes to two two
goes to four three goes to six
and after they move you see all of the
original guests are in the even-numbered
rooms
the odd-numbered rooms are vacant
and now you can put the infinitely many
people from the bus
into the odd rooms if you're in seat one
you go to room one
if you're in seat two on the bus you go
to room three
seat three goes to room five you can
actually give a general rule to get the
seat number you
double the number and subtract one and
that's the room you should go to so you
get on the bus intercom
if you're in seat k you'll be in room
2k minus 1. everyone gets a room
it's actually a little bit like a zipper
you have the original guests and the
guests from
the bus and you sort of zip them
together and you put them into the rooms
like
that you had infinitely many guests
filling infinitely many rooms but you
made room for infinitely many more
guests
you know on the grade school we would
say that
two times infinity but apparently it's
just the same as infinity
let's crank it up a notch what if two
buses pulled up
each of them with infinitely many people
on it if you've followed everything so
far
you might be able to work through and
figure out what we need to do
here's one way to do it you tell your
hotel guests if you're in room
n please move to room three ad and now
they've filled only the multiples of
three
you go to the first bus let's call it
bus a and you say
if you're in seat k you're going to go
to room 3k minus two
seat one goes to room one seat two goes
to room four seat three goes to room
seven
you're going up by three each time
you'll notice that if you divide any of
those numbers by three you get a
remainder of one
and then you go to bus b and you say if
you're in seat j
you're going to be in room three j minus
one
you're in room seat one you go to room
two seat two you go to room five
seat three you go to room eight you up
by three each time again
and again if you notice all of their
rooms when you divide by three
you get a remainder of two
well that does it for those but what if
you did something crazier what if you
had
infinitely many buses each with
infinitely many people
pull up can you still find a room for
everyone you know
in grade school terms this is like
infinity times infinity
so the question in in that language
would be is infinity times infinity
equal to infinity
the notation here gets a little
confusing you know we have numbers on
the hotel rooms
and now we have letters on the buses
we'll call them b
c but we have to pretend that the
alphabet goes on forever and
on each bus we have seats so maybe on
bus a we call those seats a1 a2 a3 a4
now amazingly it's still possible to get
everybody from the buses
into the hotel rooms i'm gonna give you
two different arguments for this
you can take your pick both i think are
fairly convincing
argument two is a little bit more mathy
but
argument one will come up again next
lecture so it's important to make sure
you follow that
here's the first argument we're going to
zigzag through the buses not not like
they might in an action film but we're
going to do this we're going to start
by lining up the new guests in a very
particular way
we're not going to take everybody from
bus a and then everybody from bus b
we can't do that because that doesn't
tell us exactly where to send the first
person on bus b
they have to go to the end of the line
behind everybody on bus a and we don't
actually have an idea where that ends
it doesn't they're infinitely many
people so instead
we take the first person from bus a and
then the second person from bus a
followed by the first person from bus b
and then the third person from a the
second person from b the first person
from c
the next four would be the fourth person
from a and then b3
c2 d1
it's actually easier to see this if we
if we sort of visualize this
if you pull the first bus up all the way
and then pull the second one up a little
bit short
and then the next sports even shorter
and then line up each bus so that
the first seat lines up with the second
seat on the previous bus
then the order of the guests is just
sort of one line after another
and every person on every bus is on
exactly one of these lines
and so you've just put these lines one
after another and then you've lined up
all of those people on the infinitely
many buses
infinitely many people on infinitely
mighty buses
and now you have one line now we have to
find them rooms in the hotel
but just like we did for one bus
we can ask the current residents to move
into the evens everybody in room
n moves to room 2n and that leaves all
the odd rooms free
you just put the infinite line of people
into the odd rooms you're the k
person in line you get the k odd room
the hard part was lining all infinitely
many people on infinitely money buses
into one line
so that's solution number one to put
them all in hotel rooms
we'll come back to this idea later let's
look at solution number two
in order to understand this there's two
important pieces of mathematical
knowledge
and they're about prime numbers remember
a prime number it's a natural number
it's bigger than one
and it's evenly divisible only by one
and itself
so one we have to know that there are
infinitely many primes
this is something euclid proved about
300 bc
actually euclid gave a recipe for
finding the next one you multiply all of
the primes you know and then you add one
the result well it's not divisible by
any of the primes you know because if
you divide by those primes
you'll have a remainder of one you added
one and that means that either that
number
is itself prime or it's divisible by
some new primes
some new primes that you didn't know
those must be larger than the ones you
did know because you can check all the
ones you didn't know
up to there and so you found yourself a
larger prime
the second thing we have to know is
unique prime factorization
every number can be uniquely written as
the product of primes
for instance if you take 28 it's 2
squared times 7 and there's no other way
to do it
so how do we use these facts to
solve our problem to put infinitely many
people on infinitely many buses
into our hotel well here's the solution
you see
like before we move the current guests
into the even rooms
and now we go back to the buses and we
label the buses with prime numbers
starting at three so there's a bus and
we'll put a three on it and the next bus
is five and then
seven and then we skip nine nine isn't
prime 11
13 15 is not prime so we take 17
19 23 and now
just to give you an example if you're on
bus number five in seat number three
you're going to go to room 5 to the
third power 5 to the third power is
5 cubed is 125. if you're in
bus number 13 seat number six room 13 to
the sixth power turns out that's
four million eight hundred twenty six
thousand eight hundred and nine
in general if you're in bus k on seat j
you're gonna go to room number k raised
to the j power
okay that was complicated let's think
about it is this correct
well we have to check to make sure is
everyone assigned a room
yeah we gave everybody on every bus a
particular room to go to
are two people assigned to the same room
that's a little bit harder so let's talk
about that you see the old guests are in
all the even rooms the new guests
they're on buses that are primes that
are bigger than two so they're all odd
and
an odd number to an odd power is also
odd an odd number to any power is odd
and so all the new guests are in odd
rooms so at least
none of the new guests are in rooms with
old guests
but are two of the new guests in the
same room
well if they started on the same bus
then definitely not because they're
going to be raised to different powers
they were
on different seats in the bus but what
if you had two people from different
buses
is it possible that when you took
different primes and raised them to
different powers
you got the same number and it turns out
that's not possible and that's what we
call
the unique prime factorization of
natural numbers
and because of the unique prime
factorization two people on different
buses
definitely have different rooms so
everybody gets
a room you might have noticed something
a little bit strange about this we've
had
infinitely many people on infinitely
many buses
and they're all accommodated with rooms
in hilbert's hotel
but there are still some rooms
unoccupied if we do it this way
all the evens are full those are the old
guess but room 15 you see 15 is 3 times
5.
it's not just a power of a single prime
so nobody's in there
any product of odd primes does the same
thing uh room 63
63 is 9 times 7. 63 is empty
in fact there are still infinitely many
rooms available
in some sense you might think that like
infinity times infinity is less than
infinity it doesn't quite
work like that but the key idea here is
to use the powers of primes
to sort of fit more stuff it turns out
that this idea
was key to girdles proof which we're
going to have to tackle later
here's a challenge question for you so
all right the hotel can accommodate
infinitely many buses each with
infinitely many passengers
what if there was a ferry out there that
was large enough to hold
infinitely many buses
imagine an infinite ferry holding buses
one two three four five each of which is
infinite
and not just one ferry but ferry number
one ferry number two ferry number three
infinitely many fairies
how can the hotel infinity accommodate
infinitely many ferries
each carrying infinitely many buses each
carrying
infinitely many passengers i think i'll
leave this for
you to figure out let's go to the quick
conundrum
[Applause]
i think you'll agree infinity doesn't
always behave nicely sometimes
you think you're out of rooms but
amazingly amazingly that's just an
illusion with sound we can do something
really similar
you might think that a rising note that
rises in pitch just goes up until
finally it gets to only
where the dogs can hear it let's listen
carefully to the pitch of the following
note
[Music]
it just keeps going up and up but
magically it comes back around to where
it started
like the infinity guests on infinity
buses all finding rooms
your intuition is really defied here so
how's this work
it's an illusion that i talk about in my
math and music course the quick version
goes like this that note is made up of
many overtones and as it gets higher the
highest overtones disappear
and low note overtones sneak in and
replace them the net effect is that the
pitch keeps going up
but doesn't end up going anywhere you
see
like infinity pitch is more complicated
than you might guess
[Music]
let's imagine that let's imagine we're
doing a lot of imagining today with all
this infinity stuff
all right so let's imagine that there's
a barrel with infinitely many
ping pong balls and next to it an empty
vase which can
also hold infinitely many ping pong
balls and next to it
an open window and finally there's a
clock on the wall
and i want to think about repeatedly
performing the following step
i'm going to take two ping pong balls
from the barrel and i'm going to put
them in the vase
and then i'm going to remove one ball
from the vase and throw it out the
window
no there's nothing strange so far well
except for the capacity of these
containers that we have here
so i want to add a little bit of
weirdness i want to make it a super task
remember a super task is where we think
about doing infinitely many steps
in a finite amount of time so
here's what's going to happen i want to
take this entire experiment
and the entire experiment is going to
take exactly one minute
in the first 30 seconds i'm going to
complete
step one i'm going to do the sequence of
things exactly once i'm going to take
two balls put them in the vase
grab one ball and from the vase throw it
out the window
so that's step one in the first 30
seconds that's done and then the next 15
seconds i'm going to do it again
step two two balls in one ball out the
window
in the next seven and a half seconds i'm
going to complete step three
two balls in one ball out the window
as we get halfway closer to one minute
i'm going to continue to complete
one step each time as we get closer to
one minute
this will has to go faster and faster
and faster and by one minute
we will have completed this infinitely
many times and the question is this
when we're done what's in the vase
all right so let's run this experiment
all right okay
so we have to watch the clock and go
all right so i have to take two balls
from this bin put them in the vase
and now throw one of these balls
out the window all right
seems like we got a lot of extra time
here
all right this first step you know
we could have done a lot more but we
were told to just do it once all right
here we come we're coming up on 30
seconds we got to do this again okay
and 30 seconds all right
go do it again okay out the window okay
even 15 seconds taking a little bit of
time
okay and we're coming up again okay
ready
and go oh and now things go faster okay
and go and go and go
all right now we're done
now let's think through how many balls
are in each place
if you want to stop and think for a
minute i'll give you a hint
amazingly the answer might depend on
whether or not the balls are actually
labeled
and if they are labeled then there are
many different answers and all of them
are possible
that's strange there are a number of
really popular
common answers to these questions and so
i'll do my best to defend each one of
these answers
and in the end we're going to go back to
these answers and we'll try to draw
conclusions and figure out
exactly what this little demonstration
which is called the ross littlewood
paradox what it tells us about infinity
so how many balls in each place the most
common answer people give is that at the
end the vase contains
infinitely many balls and the reasoning
goes something like this you see in step
one
two balls were added to the vase and one
was removed so
at the end of that step there's one ball
in the vase
step two two more balls are added that
makes three but then one was thrown out
so at the end of step two we have two
balls in the vase
step three two balls were added uh that
gets us to four and then one was thrown
out
and so that ends up with three balls in
the vase you see
after n steps there are exactly n balls
in the vase
and so n keeps going higher and higher
infinitely many steps there should be
infinitely many balls in the vase
that argument seems really
straightforward and it's very convincing
but you know that can't be it what if
these balls were numbered let's let's
number these balls one two three four
five six
and here's a claim in the end the vase
is empty
i know that sounds strange let's see if
we can justify this
well you see let's grab them out of the
barrel the original barrel in order so
step one i'm grabbing numbers one and
two and putting them in the vase
and suppose i grab from the vase as well
and so i throw number one out the window
step two i'm grabbing numbers three and
four
and putting them in the vase and now i
grab the lowest one in the vase i'm
taking those in order the lowest number
is number two
i throw it out the window steps three i
take
five and six in the vase and number
three goes out the window
here's the thing you know exactly when
each ball was removed from the vase
ball number n left at step n
and that means that every ball was taken
out of the vase
and that means the vase must be empty
another way to think of it is you think
there's a ball in the vase
what number because i threw them all out
the window
there are even stranger answers you know
suppose you wanted to end up with just
the even balls
in the vase a method well at each step
you just take out the lowest numbered
odd ball
what if you wanted to leave only ball
number 1729 in the vase
at each step you could take out the
lowest numbered ball that isn't number
1729
eventually you would get the balls 1729
and 1730 and then you would
eventually throw out 1730 and everything
above it
what if you wanted to be left with
exactly 42 balls in the vase
well the first 42 steps you could take
out the odd numbers
until you say you have evens 2 through
84 left
and after that you could just take off
the ones from 85
86 87 on up in sequence in the end you
would have balls number two through
40 84 just the evens that's 42 balls
so many answers you know if you wanted
to write it out with mathematical
notation
you might try to write it out infinity
that we put
in the vase minus infinity the ones we
take out and
infinity minus infinity apparently it
might equal infinity there might be
infinitely many balls left it might be
zero you might have none left
it might just be one number 17 29 it
might be 42
infinity minus infinity could equal any
of these things
this is why mathematicians avoid doing
equations with infinity
it's why you need a license in order to
do these sorts of things
now in math class we're used to the idea
that every question has
one right answer this question sort of
like the dog that was running between
the boy and the girl
multiple answers are possible and
they're all correct in some sense
this is sort of a true paradox in in a
technical sense
you started from basic assumptions about
barrels bases and balls
and we made logical reasonings very
step-by-step reasoning
and we arrived at contradictory
conclusions the vase is empty there's
infinitely many balls just a few
some paradoxes don't resolve in any way
those
tend to teach us something that's really
important about the world
and here we learn a lesson about
infinity infinity doesn't work the same
way as
finite numbers do the dog takes
finitely many trips back and forth his
location is definite
but if he takes infinitely many and some
of those are infinitely small it's not
so clear anymore
i move finite number of balls a finite
number of times
you know exactly where each one is but
if i do it infinitely many times
it's really not so clear you see we
develop our intuition about numbers
from the finite numbers and that
intuition completely fails us when it
comes to infinity
if you want to avoid paradoxes about
infinity don't think of it as a number
it's so much more than that
let's talk a little bit about this idea
of super tasks completing infinitely
many tasks in a finite amount of time
it leads to many different paradox it's
really closely related to zeno's
paradoxes
think about the dichotomy going halfway
to the goal each time
the philosopher james thompson thought
about a one minute game
where you turn a lamp on or off at each
time step and again
like the balls you do it once in the
first 30 seconds and then
15 seconds and then again in the seven
and a half seconds as you get halfway
toward a minute you do it again and
again
at the end of the game is the lamp on or
off
or maybe it's both in 2001
british mathematician e brian davies
used these ideas to theorize the
existence
of an infinitely powerful computer
imagine that you could create a machine
that can replicate itself
but instead of replicating exactly
itself it replicates
a faster version of itself say something
that's
double twice as quick and the next
generation
replicates itself and replicates
something which is again
twice as fast you know suppose the
machines could do simple arithmetic and
communicate each other with each other
what you end up with is arbitrarily fast
computers
no of course he admits that the physics
of quantum mechanics and thermodynamics
means this isn't actually possible
but it is interesting to think about
and really how far away from that are we
3d printing technology allows you to
make objects
we have some of them here in the studio
we'll see some later
one such printer is called a makerbot
and in 2010
a makerbot made and wait for it
another makerbot i mean this wasn't
true replication you know it needed raw
materials and
some assembly was required okay it's
quite a bit of assembly to put a
makerbot
together but how long before a machine
can self-replicate completely
and how long before it could make a
version of itself that's even
faster than that what would that mean
super tasks like these are all a bit
self-referential and they're
at the heart of a lot of paradoxes and
conundrums many of them
involving infinity in fact back in
lecture 1 we talked about
1 being equal to 0.9 repeating see
many students think of 0.9 repeating as
a super task
you keep writing down nines you never
finish or at least
you don't finish in any finite time
to understand that it actually does
equal one the super task has to somehow
have an
end you have to do infinitely many tasks
in a finite amount of time
you know another way to think about this
is using geometric series that we saw in
lecture five
to actually add them up completing a
super task
it's sort of a theoretical very
philosophical thing oh
why do we care
i'm not sure but i think that there's a
lecture on infinity
that might help us make sense of what's
going on
we're running out of time and so i'll
speed it up a little bit
i'm not sure but i think it might help
us
thankfully you can sum a geometric
series and get a finite number
and apparently i can do a super task or
at least sort of fake it otherwise this
lecture would never have ended
next time we're going to revisit hotel
infinity and its infinite buses
and we'll see how mathematicians
eventually learned to tame infinity
[Music]
you